black music icons on the big screen
kevin chose this song the song is
beautiful
i made her a promise i said you'll be
very proud of yourself at the end of
this movie
[Music]
and the performances that immortalize
recording industry pioneers
she's just energy personified
i want y'all to give it up for ice cubes
our art is a reflection of our reality
i worked for two years to get the road
at certain points i was thinking we was
looking at the young nwa
a special episode of et's the download
starts right now
with june being black music month we're
spending today's episode celebrating the
voices who inspired movie magic and
stars singing and acting their way into
history including whitney houston she's
the biggest reason the bodyguard still
has the best selling soundtrack of all
time
[Music]
did you have any reservations about
making it the theme for this movie
not at all
not at all i thought about wow what a
beautiful song dolly wrote i'm gonna do
it you know it was number one in the 70s
and then again in the 80s when we used
it in best little chicken house but it
did not have the success that it's had
with whitney houston
[Music]
you know kevin chose this song i
listened to it and i said you know
you're absolutely right this is the song
and i made her a promise i said you'll
be very proud of yourself at the end of
this movie
[Music]
she nailed her next soundtrack too
but there comes a point when
when we accept well
hello hello
you look better than i remember
[Music]
i mean i've been humming this thing
have you been shooting since dawn yeah
good so good in fact whitney's hit off
the waiting to exhale album earned a
grammy for best r b song i liked
the fact that there was finally going to
be a film about african-american women
finally i say savannah is me without the
fame oh yeah
savannah can get down
and so can whitney
another role that wasn't quite as spicy
but still hit close to home the
preacher's wife i believe in you and me
you know the gospel of course enticed me
the gospel music and whitney's co-star
denzel washington i remember one night
denzel cornered me and he said whitney
you're going to do this movie he said
plus you know you could sing gospel
and i said didn't tell you you've never
heard me sing gospel he said yeah but
i've heard your mother
i thought boy you know you know how to
get me good right whitney made so much
sense for so many reasons she grew up in
the church he sang in the choir the 1996
film proved whitney's triple threat
status actor producer and gospel singer
[Music]
you were singing joy to the world and
penny marshall directing yelled cut
the spirit
came over all of us george mass and
myself
and i continued the song just the level
of spirit that came in that place was
like electricity
another religious experience whitney's
final film role and her final e.t
interview for sparkle it's the story of
a young woman's journey to stardom she
plays emma anderson jordan sparks aka
sparkles strict christian mom
it's not so much about me with houston
it's about just being that vessel
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
another on-screen icon gone too soon
chadwick boseman who embodied music
legend james brown
one day everybody gonna know your name
[Applause]
james man
well yeah in character you were mr brown
it's true
it took chadwick just two months to
fully transform
i listened to a lot of footage and a lot
of his albums and i had a fabulous voice
coach a singing coach and we talked
about how his singing voice and his
speaking voice were in the same
placement it's the same like closing of
the vocal chords danger never die
and when it comes to the godfather of
seoul's signature moves well chadwick
performed those all himself 15 hours
split after split after split move out
the move even more exhausting bringing
brown's demons to life what's the
darkest moment that you have to play
from james brown's life him doing pcp
the relationship with his wife like the
domestic abuse emotionally that was a
difficult in the scene with his mother
my baby playing at the apollo i hate the
sugar i hate you baby what is it with
you playing real-life characters it has
nothing to do with them
being real characters i think
as african americans and people in
african diaspora period
a lot of our stories haven't been told
another such story
ma rainey's black bottom
levi the sooner you understand it and
what you say is what my state account
chadwick played the fictitious levee
green traditionally depicted as a
trumpeter bozeman played the cornet in
the netflix version of ma rainey's band
i'm gonna give me a bed and make me some
records viola davis played the mother of
the blues
[Music]
there was nothing about chadwick
that
was anything other than a life force i
got my time coming to me
sadly the role mart chadwick's last he
died on august 28 2020 after a secret
four-year battle with colon cancer did
you all didn't know that chadwick was
sick when he was doing this no idea
boseman went on to become the first
posthumous golden globe winner he's also
the first black performer to receive a
posthumous oscar nod for his ma rainey
role
he's just one of those people you meet
every once in a lifetime
not to mention an incredible gift and
legacy
all right andrade had her once in a
lifetime moment when she became just the
second black woman to win a best actress
golden globe for her portrayal of billie
holiday both of you are under arrest
stop it
stop
since whoopi goldberg in the color
purple only the second black woman you
know that's another layer of just
wow
people don't understand
what your journey was like and how hard
you work to get to this moment you know
it's a slow burn
andra's commitment to the role went far
beyond acting she lost 39 pounds to play
the late singer who had a very public
battle with drugs and alcohol before her
untimely death at 44.
we didn't want to work out too much
because i told him in the beginning i
said you guys i cannot show up to set
with an eight pack it's not great to say
it but i did starve myself the word on
the street is you took up smoking and
drinking to take on this roll i i did my
body was like what the [ __ ] is going on
i needed it i had to feel her in my body
trees
they're strange
fruit
but andrew actually had to be convinced
to audition according to the film's
director lee daniels
i don't think she wanted the job at
first you know when she opens her mouth
you saw i saw
i saw an artist
god bless the child
here's a fun fact lee's first job was on
purple rain i know what's that about
that's crazy
i came to hollywood with seven dollars
in my pocket i drilled one a lot and i
said i'm ready to be a pa in casting
let's go
hey
the year was 1984 when prince a five
foot two inch stick of dynamite and high
heeled boots taught us how to party like
it was 1999.
[Music]
the movie was loosely based on his own
life with prince playing the kid a young
musician struggling with family issues
i saw mom up the street
she looked pretty bad
any idea how she got that way
if i get married
and of course he had the hottest
girlfriend played by apollonia catero
[Music]
i'm not your ordinary average type of
woman
[Applause]
purple rain was a hit on every level
earning 70 million at the box office the
soundtrack was number one for 24 weeks
straight and the icing on the cake and
oscar for best original song score i
could never imagine this in my wildest
dreams thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you know what's more iconic than that
win for purple rain what he wore to the
oscars
all right jimmy fox earned his own oscar
by diving in head first to his career
defining role in ray jamie foxx and ray
a lot of the academy members that came
up to me would say that was my error
that was my music
[Music]
you can't do that around me man i ate
man i get excited
fox's total transformation into ray
charles included eye prosthetics that
made him blind for up to 14 hours a day
he learned braille he played the piano
in all these scenes and he dropped a lot
of weight
i walk around 190 pounds i lost 30
pounds 157 pounds she knows how to
take that thing and it's just a matter
of how he orders his food how he talks
to his woman
uh
how he gets mad but he internalizes real
things how he does his business and
those are the things that you're feeling
i admire what you're doing man but you
can't afford this george is our highest
grossing just play any mortals jim crow
joints ever again did you got that and
then all the family members how they
would react or
uh certain times that his son would
leave the sets it's too real it's too
real right now the deepness is
is the stories the music for one the
music slings you all the way back in the
1940s and 50s i mean when you start
singing i got a woman you feel it and
then that's where the impersonation
helps you the in the performing of them
[Music]
the musician played a major role helping
fox bring his persona to the big screen
yeah there you go
it's uh what i do
i don't know how i just take a little
little thing in the phone
[Music]
[Laughter]
the film which focuses on 30 years of
charles's life premiered just three
months after he died of liver failure in
2004 in fact the rachel's got a chance
to view the movie before he passed he
worked along with the move for 15 years
everything in the story
is from his mouth
[Music]
tina turner was also hyper involved when
her biography hit the big screen and
only e.t was there when she came face to
face with the woman who won the lead
role angela bassett
i'm showing up
i never wore that
any nervousness or apprehension it just
flies right out of the window and she
just has been right there for me
[Music]
you know she's just energy personified
you know and the fact i've had to get in
shape physically you know and just the
stamina that's required to do half a
proud mary
[Music]
yep angela worked hard to transform into
the rock and roll legend but opted to
lip sync her iconic songs hey could you
imagine someone trying to sing like tina
you know i'm just trying to act it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and those abuse scenes
well angela was dedicated to those two
in this part where she falls off the
couch she reportedly suffered a hairline
fracture in her hand i mean emotionally
it's draining
my knee hurts and your ankle and you
know i mean she really went through this
it's been so important that i have
someone playing playing ike that i'm
playing opposite
that i just trust you know immeasurably
that person was angela's co-star
lawrence fishburn i spoke to ike very
briefly for about five minutes he asked
me what i was trying to do and i said i
was trying to be him and he said do a
good job and he turned down the role of
ike five times he didn't say yes until
angela landed the job too angela and i
were meant to do a movie a long time ago
that never got made it just seems like
we were meant to
to have a really
wonderful piece
in which the both of us could kind of do
our thing the film earned both stars
their first and only oscar nominations
with angela taking home the golden globe
in 1994. whoever liked it or didn't like
it
i gave it all i had
giving it her all jennifer hudson as
aretha franklin in respect hand-picked
by the queen of soul herself before her
death in 2018.
what did it mean to you to play aretha
it's a role of a lifetime you know to
betray a legend and to be chosen by her
to play her is i'm still in you know eye
of it we lost a legend but then someone
lost a family member mother eddie
talk to me about yourself he knows a lot
about aretha he even got the opportunity
to meet miss franklin one of our last
conversations was about him cooking and
me sending her a video of him cooking
because she loves to cook and he loves
to cook and the passion they shared
singing in fact j-hud did all her vocals
live on the
[Music]
[Applause]
set jennifer has to unlearn the song
because i wanted to experience it as she
did
[Music]
my doctor said take it easy she was able
to communicate a feeling an emotion a
moment through a song she taught me how
to do that
cynthia arrivo was emmy nominated for
her portrayal of aretha ingenious i
found out when i was doing a photo shoot
and then proceeded to ball my eyes out
and cry feels like she's tapped me on
the shoulder and gone well done what
does it feel like though the people that
now want to compare the aretha projects
i would say why not enjoy the two
versions we're both artists in our own
right
both triple threats j hud becoming just
the second black woman to win an emmy
grammy oscar and tony and cynthia's just
one win away from locking in her own
egot status i got this great new take on
respect it's just an overwhelming
feeling to
be celebrated for the work that you do
and she's doing it all with style i
obviously have a passion for fashion and
yes i did spend the pandemic basically
dressing up if it was to walk to the
kitchen then i would have an outfit for
it
and i just walked to my kitchen still in
sweats
well listen here's someone else who
knows a thing or two about fashion
coming up beyonce's drastic dream girls
diet eggs for downloads we'll be right
back
drop it
[Applause]
i mean it just never gets old homecoming
put beyonce in the record books as the
first black woman to headline coachella
the spectacle which required eight
months of rehearsals was a love letter
to historically black colleges and
universities fusing african-american
culture with a marching band that was
turned all the way up bee has been known
to put in work to feed her fans which is
exactly what she did as a dream girl in
2006.
[Music]
it was 40 something different hairstyles
and makeup changes and beautiful gowns
first half of the movie they downplayed
gina and made a really plain tina jones
you know no makeup in these really weird
eyebrows it's sophisticated
this is the first role i was able to do
that i can show that i'm a true actor
and i have the chops beyonce demanded
everyone stop and listen to her as the
soft-spoken dina jones listen
it was a transformative role i didn't
recognize myself at one point i said to
my mom oh i can't
hand her i'm talking about dina and i
really forgot it was me
first of all beyonce in a respectful way
she's she's the bang bang boogie yeah
and i'm saying that very respected bang
bang
boogie this is the cherry the nuts the
sauce the cream and the banana too
and let's talk about the preparation
i lost 20 pounds and i couldn't lose
that weight for myself but i lost it for
the movie because i can't i love to eat
i fasted and only drink liquids and fish
and protein shakes and vegetables and
for six months
[Music]
i gained
about 20 pounds for the roll waking up
in the middle of night eating cookies
cakes and pies
[Music]
it was jennifer hudson's first movie
role and a dream for the former american
idol finalist every experience prepares
you for the next
and i am telling
jennifer hudson she lays it out she's
crashing out of the park
effortlessly eddie murphy and j hud were
both oscar nominated for their roles but
on the night of the academy awards
jennifer hudson
i have to just take this moment in
now where is this gorgeous man going
it's gone in my new house i wanted to
have theme music i wanted to say
well now that she's got that ego her
house is going bing bing bing bing
all right from motown to ice cube and dr
dre who both had a hand in bringing
their origin story as artists in nwa to
the big screen
yo trey
what up i got something to say
[Music]
the richest story the whole
legacy of nwa is we believed in
ourselves and we didn't let nobody stop
us at q
what's your poem now
the flyers one you know
what is it like watching your child
portray you he got everything right you
know it was like when we was editing
this movie at certain points i was
thinking we was looking at the young nwa
they want nwa
let's give him nwa
we put him through it we put him through
it he worked the hardest to get the role
we didn't hand him the role because
i'm not going to just give him the role
because he looks like his dad he still
has to carry an entire movie and he did
i worked for two years to get the world
two years of auditions and call backs i
wanted
him to earn it
what was it like when you first saw it
goose bumps i got a cold ass beam that
hardcore reality rap so what you talking
about doing cruising down the street in
my sixth phone
hey that was dope
it's like meeting your your hero man i
remember dre
specifically he was just like i don't
want you to try to
you know get this writing the mechanics
right in this he said you got all that
you're an actor you know what you're
doing you got the job but i want you to
capture what we were trying to say at
that time and capture our humanity
[Music]
[Music]
i mean good luck getting that song out
of your head today uh spike lee
commissioned debut for his movie school
days in 1988 and it became a surprise
hit for experience unlimited better
known as eu it hit number one on
billboard's r b charts and i mean just
last year at the oscars glenn close
reminded everyone just how fun it is to
dance to
you know how to do the butt quest turn
up
come on let's see let me see through the
butt let's see it
[Music]
go
daddy go daddy
[Applause]
we're gonna let that play us out be sure
to join us back here on monday for an
all new episode of eating the download
bye
[Music]
i